Here are five great summer destinations in Asia.
Number five: Travel to Kyoto, Japan,...
...the seventh largest city in Japan.
Magical architecture with rich cultural heritage...
...like shrines and temples will surround you...
...or visit its traditional neighborhoods.
You are likely to see geishas in their traditional attire.
Number four: Kerala, India, is a place unlike any other.
The backwaters of Kerala are truly remarkable waterways,...
...wild yet serene, remote yet inhabited.
There are hundreds of miles of canals, rivers, lagoons and lakes.
Number three: Siem Reap, Cambodia, is rustic eye candy.
Close by are the world famous Angkor Wat temples with centuries of history.
Visitors also flock to Old Market for a unique shopping and dining experience,...
...making a trip here far from ordinary.
Number two is Bali, Indonesia.
Bali's beaches are among the best in the world.
Spectacular vistas surround you.
Take time to surf and enjoy sunsets.
You can find a temple anywhere you imagine in Bali, Indonesia.
And number one: Kandy, Sri Lanka, called the country's cultural capital,...
...is a visitor's delight with an abundance of sights.
Visit the Temple of Tooth.
It is said to be the resting place of one of Buddha's teeth...
...or wander through the historical colonial architecture.